[Music]
this morning thousands of people in
louisiana still don't have power more
than a month after hurricane ida slammed
into the coast ida took out more power
poles than hurricane katrina crews have
been working around the clock to make
repairs jesse missile recently went down
to southern louisiana to see how one
hard-hit family was coping
we are driving into the town of golden
meadow
it's about an hour and a half south of
new orleans
they have tarps on roofs still no power
and today it's raining
hi
it was long
it took us about three hours to get here
about that yeah have you gotten any
leaks yet today
no my nephew came reinforced
the the tarps yesterday oh that's good
it's not leaking inside we've been
hanging clothes in the shed
get it out of the rain to dry
before hurricane ida crystal hodge lived
in this two-bedroom house her
grandfather built with her mother since
the storm we've taken on additional
family members
my daughter her daughter
my daughter's mother-in-law and my niece
and that's all of us six ladies four
generations one house what's it like
it's chaos
but i i love them so much
we all do what we can yes ma'am the food
is mostly set out on the table so we
don't have to be digging in the dark for
food
this way is my bedroom
every frame has at least one window brew
so i put cardboard but i need i'm gonna
find a better solution so who's sleeping
in here with you how do you mean the
baby all three of y'all no wonder you're
not sleeping alive i just bought this
bed last month
the brand new bed brand new mattress it
got a little moisture so i hope the
towel i haven't eaten is is absorbing
any moisture i just paid a good price
for this and thank god i think he got
spammed so far so good
the family's surviving with the help of
this 900 dollar generator so then how
often do you refill it
daily oh yeah daily
but this will last all day and all night
we don't rent it all day and all night
so it lasts that long
but i'm sure it would take two of these
if you would rather all day take 10
gallons a day if you would run it 24 i
would see
what all does the generator plug into
right now
the
in the two back rooms
a fan in the living room the ice box
and i guess she's probably gonna need
like enthusiasts
yeah okay she must depress reset
linemen have been working nonstop since
the august 29 storm but it's a labor
intensive process and there are still
thousands without power you know jesse
see if we pull these down too
yeah
fixture came off yeah i think you need
to get underneath there
i know huh
in the attic you can feel it you don't
even have to smell it you can feel that
moisture in here
what's your biggest concern now
the mildew
in the ceiling
and mold growing
and contaminating it that will be
unlivable here it won't be able to live
here
if it's all contaminated with mold
we don't have flood insurance mom
we have only fire i was wrong yeah
so no flood and no wind insurance what
are you going to do
i'm going to hopefully get back to work
and make the repairs we have to make to
live here
but right now crystal is also in the
dark about whether she has a job the
restaurant where she and her daughter
worked was badly damaged in the storm
just the batteries i've been buying has
been draining my account
batteries changing the batteries for the
flashlights buying gasoline for the
generator
all these little costs so i saved the
receipts
and maybe
fema will help maybe not but i have all
my receipts saved to show them
what i've been spending
i've been hearing
a 500 check people have been getting
but you don't know what you're getting
no man and it won't be enough to cover
the repairs of the house no no not if
it's just that amount do you feel
forgotten about
oh no no
i have faith in the lord and i'm not
forgotten mom and i aren't forgotten my
daughter no
we have a lot more than other people i'm
thankful for what we have
because there's a lot worse off
resilience of folks in louisiana
incredible that was jesse mitchell
reporting from golden medal louisiana
now jesse tells us that power did
finally come back on for crystal and her
family just this week i know but the on
ending misery it seems for so many
families down there uh the resilience is
the word for it yeah jesse mitchell
thank you very much come